we have an interesting variety of
documentary films this year they are all
unique in their own way and serve as
proof of how powerful a well-made
documentary film candy our bronze medal
winning film was made at a school that
has been no stranger to our Awards
created at Stanford University by
filmmaker Theo rib be simple spanish for
without country is the story of the Maha
family if the living working and raising
a family in California for nearly 20
years the parents are suddenly faced
with the threat of deportation well I
think the only way I could totally
completely bomb this speech right now is
if I forget to thank my mom so mom thank
you for everything in all of your
support and how that you do for me I can
move on now really really I mean talking
about thanking people i mean the only
people i can think of are the mejia
family and I'm incredibly lucky
incredibly blessed to be joined by many
of the Mejia family tonight so please if
you could stand up and be recognized
I mean I came I met them I hear family
two weeks before that night but you just
saw and I came into your house and all
SAT around on a living room and I don't
even remember what I said but I
basically pitched the idea of you know
this big bearded stranger coming into
your life in the most difficult most
emotional most insane kind of
circumstances that I can imagine have
ever happened to you and you let me in
from that first second and with what the
most the most warmth and love and
acceptance that that I could ever ask
for from not just from a film or you
know film subjects but from from family
so I I thank you just from from the
deepest deepest depths of my heart and I
feel truly honored to know you and and
and to have been to been there with you
through the past two years I really want
to thank everyone who worked on this
with me stanford university is a very
small class just eight of us in each
class so all of my classmates and my
teachers giant Kravitz / Samuelson Jamie
Meltzer Johnny Simon's the film would
not be here without them and and the
Academy I mean that this entire week has
just been I haven't processed it yet and
it's going to take a long time to
process it but i don't know i think
they're the really i find inspiration in
a lot of different places at various
times but you know the really few
moments in life where where it's just
glaring and clear that that you're doing
the right thing that like this path that
I'm going down I didn't know where it
started with this film I didn't know
that it was going to be here a year ago
or two years ago but but it's right and
and I just need to keep fighting and
keep working incredibly hard to get
documentaries made as it gets harder and
harder and and the Academy I truly thank
you for that
and my family for supporting for never
even second guessing that you know going
into this this field was a good idea it
was just always a good idea and and
finally to Katina it's my fiance I could
not do any of this without you and going
through grad school with a partner in
grad school is kind of a horrendous
thing to do so thank you and I guess our
wedding has to be better than this
somehow so I'm gonna work on it I'll
make sure it's gonna be good trust me
thank you everyone